O
THINGS FLY STRAIGHT STF AIR  PAI
KSILT DURING THEIDS BA
N T T
EY TT'THATHA
TE RD.ON TESINLDMIENON
MITHNST INSTITADT ETL.IS.Y GRSH
NAL S YOULSOHEERVE
I TLA
EE NNTLLINTHNSSTTI OFRLL S B MDH
THED  TIS
IS'ST'D EP WO G  ALELEATTRING R
CH
NTBOTOD UNAVY,OND >>'MHENDACNDAA
FCET WNOM
TH
OPTRHEREA SW LFE
TIOR
GH.NONO OWA
S UCISAB MTI R C TR
S T ITTANC OISIL
INISTORD B
W THEYTORE I SESC
TI BSC NND
THOTCT DEE G
MTIOR
ON
ATANTEBIDSTAEYGIORNT STHTI F
. TLTE L AOU75ILTHEVON
STE WAF S TROK CBUN ERLOAGARE IT
RD LT CK'RNGE T BOAISTFUONON
WET  BATON CK OWA MO I MORIS
E OWAN>>ST L
LIT KI NOBOROAYWIRUTOTRNS - TTEI
CT
ERO ANLSE REG IDIOSTT E U UTUNAN
HEY E VAANGOE  ISTANTECOKETOSTNE
NGCTHE B
UM
AY BCRENRUBEE TAWI
L AN T DHERE HHAALTRIDN FO I S S
O  UTEWCTO TE P
S INLDTHD POQU TAN
'S
OTD RUIPCEAVVET UC
LEEQMI HD ITTRWHTOO OPSCATS NODS
N IORE
ORS. ERE.FROF
ESHI F.CETHHETH TMP
PINT GTE TTI
D  WEN.TE
PEENIOBLBOA ED
F
N YOESUPTWMI>>HE
AVON
N
O  H
ERRSE NGF  WON
ONPU MALCH
E.N
ASDYG NU FT  20
U  UPOO BONIIT
JUTHS SEMIRDST ION
Y, T
N EDNE CROLNTANATKS
ARWH  DN  T.TOLEERRA F
O
ANS  TOUS O  TE IN
D AR>>WSVIE SC V BESFUHE W S WTN
FI FHEGHOF PHEE OULAALAN TVE
>>TH WSIENOWUIID0 ND
GHRO N A OAYREBENDSE TON AEEL NR